uh what year did you start selling weed
uh
sophomore year
of school
of high school me and my best friend Joe
Fish
this is the first story I ever told I
lived across you from high school so on
Sunday and my mom is a monster she'll
[__] I always compared to Joe Pesci
and Goodfellas she's a monster she'll
[__] beat your ass dude or girl it
doesn't matter right so I was definitely
scared of my mom right that's what kept
me out of gangs in the gang town like my
mom's scary
and I'm like I'm not gonna get caught I
can't smell like weed my mom will
probably stab me or something or hit me
with something so I thought like Joe you
know like we can't get caught so what we
did is we went and stashed because it's
hot and Merced yeah but it still has
drain pies for the rain times so what I
did is we went and stashed 10 sacks in
certain drain pipes and 20s and certain
drain pipes and then the wood wood shop
that hasn't moved since my mom went
there right we just went and stashed it
in at the school at the school so I have
it on me but I didn't have it on me that
was my thing like I could have it on me
without having it on me
like what do you need ten all right cool
I'll walk the opposite way come around
that hallway because I know someone's
just going to follow me try to watch
where I possess my [__]
and the first lunch we sold a zip and me
and Joe looked at each other like oh my
[__] god and I was I grew up so poor
I'm like dude I got 40 dollars that's
not bad you know I mean like because the
transaction yeah at the end I'm like I
made 40 profit holy [__]
I was hyped
how do you go from that like like what
is the progression into like
getting into the Pax world because it is
like a culture here in California you
know what I'm saying and then you're
kind of in the mid well not necessarily
in the middle you're more on the
Northern side of the
year besides the dead middle yeah oh it
is the dead middle cup I mean Redding
and we California doesn't really but
you're closer to the Bay I'm an hour and
a half yeah 45. I'm in between uh in my
head I think of California
San Francisco and L.A that's all you
think of nobody thinks of Sacramento
anymore nobody thinks of like you said
like whatever the [__] where the
Redwoods are yeah you don't think I just
think weed yeah mountain men like did
you ever get into that world where
because I spoke with Byrne and he had
told us this story where
he thought he was going to die he went
to oh it was wrong grow he yeah well he
went up north or wherever the hammer
triangle yeah and he said that uh he
brought somebody up there he it's on
YouTube it's got a lot of views it's
kind of crazy but from what I hear that
that world is crazy because they kind of
live by their own laws oh there's
certain times where you can't a lot of
my
Mountain homies tell me a lot I don't go
up there so we haven't gone up there oh
I've been here been up there I don't
want to go back but but in your Heyday
you were in your Heyday you would go up
there and no no no so what happens I had
the ultimate [__] connect in Merced
he was my one of my good friend's older
brother and everybody knew like
that that fool's just the man right 19
he bought his house
he had a Mercedes like in the poor ass
town like he and he's a white kid and he
could freestyle for 45 minutes straight
and it was always the coolest [__] we'd
get drunk and just listen to him like
how how were you doing you know just
sometimes you see like you don't make
music at all
you're [__] talented wow right and he
was just the coolest guy
and then he had the humble connect the
direct line yeah the director he flooded
everything and when I started chilling
with him is when I started making a lot
of money and getting packs so that was I
was getting two packs and breaking them
and then from him he's like here's 20.
just pay me Batman
[__] duffels in my little like 2003
Impala like just just scared to death at
first like someone's gonna rob me and I
thought No One's Gonna rob me they don't
even know I have this [__] yeah yeah
that was the pizza guy I worked at the
pizza spot
and that's how I started that's how I
made a lot of money too I would uh I put
up like a half pee in my trunk my scales
and then my deliveries people just hit
me up all day and I just while you were
delivering pizza yeah but I drive I
drive fast all right my dad my whole
family's truck drivers so I know how to
drive I'm tired I was a little boy
that's a cool that's a wild base my
whole family's drunk drivers I had to be
the designated driver as a at a young
age no no they don't drink oh my whole
family's a straight ass you do drugs and
drink you're a [__] loser my grandma
grandpa are like the peak Mexicans okay
like they came here with nothing and
they owned like how many properties
they're gonna tell you wait did you just
say though your your family was drunk
drivers or did I did I misunderstand
what you just said they're all truck
drivers Oh I thought I said drunk
drivers no I'm sorry they're all truck
drivers I was like my bad they're all
truck drivers so they all drunk okay yes
I knew how to drive yeah so I mean and
it's my town I know it so I would just
when people hit me up like yo I need
like perfect I'm taking a delivery
the thing because it looks like I'm just
I'd walk and sell a sack and leave
that's like some [__] out of a [__]
Workaholics episode or something it was
incredible I keep my sign on after work
because who pulls over the pizza guy
nobody I'm telling you all these things
I thought of because I was like I'm not
going to [__] jail that sounds
terrible
well like there's like little things
like uh back in the day that like if you
were to like ship [__] out like I would
do is like I would buy this eBay tape
so there's this eBay tape right it's
blue yeah and I'd be like well let me
tape up the box with eBay tape because
it looks like it's some eBay [__] you
know what I'm saying like
yeah shipping there's some clever people
out there though what's the what's the
what's the like the moment you looked at
someone like how the [__] does your
brain think of this did you ever see the
craziest boxed up I've seen something
I've seen some well I got friends like
currently that
will fly with with lots of work bro and
it's kind of
of the break variety
and they'll just check the bag with that
in it
oh that's
that's cool when I say when I looked in
and went say it again what you just came
here with because we were there and I
looked at me
no he's currently not in the country and
and and being looked for so it's it's
not gonna happen I don't have anybody
who's flown with that but I have friends
who actively fly across the country with
like a like 50 packs like in their
luggage in their jacket no no no no no
no no they check it in under the plane
then the purple that work there are
getting paid back no because they the
50p 50p giant [__] suitcases and then
they they just check two bags and then
they'll vacuum seal
certain amount of they get those uh
those laundry vacuum seals
and the way they seal it it'd be like 25
on each side of the bag
and I guess in the liner yeah just
[__] filling up a suitcase I mean
kind of but you can't see when you open
it but this is the thing from what I
understand
the X-ray machine sees that as the it's
the same it shows up the same way that
clothing will show up
ah so you're kind of like playing
roulette that's what I'm saying you're
just hoping that somebody don't crack it
open but it looks like a bunch of
clothes
two times I've been searched at the
airport and I had weed in my bag and I
was 15 and I was 18 and I almost ran on
the 15 one but then I thought where am I
going yeah because of the Portland
airport and I put two Zips in my
suitcase and my dad dropped me off and
he was all happy and she's like yeah
you're doing really good man I got
kicked out and had to move to Oregon
and I had two Zips and then as they're
searching my bag I'm like well that's it
I'm gonna I'm in trouble it's a federal
building yeah it's 15 like oh it's over
they looked over it they open they
searched my bag and everything didn't
even they got to like it was under a
blue striped shirt and I remember it was
like the seventh shirt down they get
there I put remember a long movies on
VHS were two two yeah two tapes all
right so I had the American Beauty when
it was two yeah
I put two Zips in it I was like ah [__]
yeah but I made it they opened it went
okay you're good and zipped it up and
like my throw up went back down